if you go to the gym just start doing
the lifts uh and right away those will
technically prepare you what are what
are the lifts can we describe yeah so
i'd say if you want to just keep it very
very simple let's just talk about three
there's more there's much more than
three
but like when you talk about energy
allocation
these three lifts in my opinion
should be like
90 of your investment is very big these
three lifts
uh
and
the exact percentages can you can argue
about it but we'll we'll start off with
the cupping of the wrist
just this this is a simple thing
and do it with a cable uh
you know you can get a thicker diameter
so it kind of you know is is more out on
your fingers where an armrest is going
to attack you right because any good
armrest is going to attack your fingers
so like open hand no no well i mean for
health yes you could
but like if you want to be really
specific you train exactly the way you
would at a table in the position that
you actually start the match yeah and
then you're just doing uh this kind of
yes to your center your people people
one of the one of the big misconceptions
in arm wrestling is that you're aiming
for that pin pad right
no the
center
the chest up bring it close to you
make it come close to you right you see
like whenever i do my exercises the the
vector is always pulling straight
towards me yeah yeah so just uh you know
cupping
close to you the most dangerous thing
that a person can do to me on an arm
missing match is just pull me away from
my body
that that's a terrible thing for me
yeah so so that cupping
yeah that's a massive part of the sport
uh so
now when you think what does the cup do
to the other person
if i cup
they get turned over
right
so this has to get really strong
this pronation so
see to fight the
to fight that rolling exactly yeah so
that's that's through the thumb
yeah
oh so you put uh
got it you put on the thumb and you put
this motion yeah
got it yeah and those two things those
two things together this cupping and
rolling
this is what's going to make the
person's hand bend back
and once the person's hand is bent back
they're just their whole game gets cut
to pieces they have very little good
options it's all like nasty stuff
wow yeah so those two things that's a
that's a huge part of of your of your
investment uh
rise
always be climbing yeah
exactly
yeah those three simple things
that's what i would tell anybody to
spend most their time on if you want to
become an art wrestler so and to use
bands would be good for this bands are
great because they're easy to transport
the only problem i have with bands is
like if you like to measure you know if
you like to be precise bands just aren't
that precise right so to have growth
yeah yeah just i mean it's just like you
know you know exactly what you need the
prescription is kind of a band is kind
of like and a lot of people myself
included i like to um i like to know
exactly
my outputs so so weights
so it would be like cables yep cables
are nice bands are great too i i i mix
the two bands are
uh when i kind of don't need to
they're more like easy for me i when i
train bands
bands are dangerous because the
acceleration is so high on them like
when you screw up with band training the
acceleration is way faster than gravity
right so if you do something bad it can
can make it go really much worse yeah
it's funny that you didn't mention
bicep curls or uh well it's a chain
it's a chain and so you're i mean the
idea if you focus on these three the
other stuff catches up like it's all
involved this whole this whole thing is
involved so
if you have an axe
right
the blade of the axe
that's that's these things
right
like you need the the pointy end of all
your attacks to be awesome
right if you have a super sharp axe yeah
you could have a shitty hand
yeah
right yeah so focus on that the point
the yeah tip of the axe yeah the tip of
the axe is so important right like if i
have an awesome bicep and i can't quite
use it what's it good for
you